Since some people in the comments want to stir up some
ballerina farm esque stove drama on my page,
I thought I'd clean up a few questions about my stove.
Just show you how easy it is to grab one of these stoves
for a pretty reasonable price.
This is a Chambers Model C.
This is a gas stove that can be set to propane or natural gas
depending on what you need it to be.
When I got it it was set for natural gas and I changed the propane.
Super easy. You just adjust the burners.
Mine is a late 1950s model,
one of the last ones they made before they changed
like a 70s model. I haven't seen in person,
but let's see if we can find some on marketplace
since I swear to you I got mine on marketplace for $200.
So I'm gonna do a search for Atlanta because that's where I am
and the first one that pops up is one that's been for sale since.
I previously was looking to buy mine and this is beautiful,
but it's at an antique store and it's super overpriced.
The colour makes you think that it's worth more,
but being an antique store you don't even know if it works.
Now this guy. He also was selling when I bought mine
and I almost bought this one because it had the firmer baker
which is right there on top of firmerwell Baker
and they're really hard To find they're actually worth like
500 bucks by themselves. And he kinda knew that.
And the stove was in a terrible condition.
But all the extra parts were worth more than the stove,
as you can see here.
There's lots of rust right here on the chrome right here.
This stove would need to be rechromed.
That wouldn't buff out. That's just lots of surface rust.
The knobs right here got surface rust.
And there's lots of rust going on inside here.
This is not been stored well.
Mine had a little bit of rust and dirt,
but not like this. This is a lot.
And it would need, you know,
A severe restoration by professional.
Not something you could handle
unless you had, um,
machines to re chrome and re enamel things.
So this is why this guy still has it.
And I think he's an antique store or antique booth, too.
And then I got tricked by this stupid Etsy link.
Like, oh my gosh,
I hate it on marketplace. I'm like,
oh my god, such a cute item!
And I'm like, no,
it's a link. Don't take me there.
Okay, so I don't think this is definitely my chambers,
but super cute nonetheless.
Let's carry on looking. This is a cute Roper stove.
Roper stoves are really cheap.
Back in the day, chambers was not a cheap stove.
So they still are cheap now. $75.
It looks kinda rough. I'm not seeing anymore locally,
so let's Widen the search.
Okay, let's see
those two. Original.
Oh, I saw one there.
Why did I scroll by? I scroll by one.
My dogs won't stop barking.
This is a cute tapanga stove.
This is actually really beautiful,
and I would definitely consider purchasing this one.
Let's do some more research.
For $200, that is a beautiful stove.
And that looks like it was in pretty good condition as well.
Life of having livestock. Guardian dogs at night.
They do not shut up all night long.
Okay, I was actually like,
why is this so expensive? It does come with a backsplash and event hood,
but they're not. Chambers vent hood.
You can get a chambers vent hood.
I've seen them once or twice,
but, um,
this is severely overpriced.
It's in decent condition, but again,
this is like a vendor or, like,
an antique booth, so
they're actually gonna have absolutely no information about the stove.
They're not gonna know anything about it.
They're not gonna know if it works,
but they wanna charge you, like,
$2,000 for it, when you could get something similar for, like, $500.
You just to keep looking. I wouldn't buy from a.
An antique booth,
because they literally are not gonna help you set it up.
They're not gonna help you do anything,
and it's gonna be filthy dirty.
So if you're gonna pay that price,
get it from an antique stove restoration company,
not from a booth. Yeah,
I would stay Away from this one,
it's severely overpriced. For that price,
I would want it to be fully renovated.
Or half renovated at least.
Refurbish, whatever you wanna call it.
I spy another one right there. $500.
This one doesn't look well.
It's got a lot of surface rust in the back there.
Let's see where this one is.
I don't know. It says working when removed.
So that's like a. A classic line that a lot of people like to say,
like, working when removed.
Well, it worked when it was removed,
but a lot of things that happened since then.
Mine was working when it was removed,
but then it didn't work because it had cockroaches in the gas line,
so they had to be cleaned out.
But, yeah,
just because it was working.
Were removed. Even just moving the stove
can knock some of the settings out of alignment,
and it won't work again. So
just because it was working
doesn't mean that you're not gonna have to help,
like, read the manual or have someone come out.
If you don't. If you're not handy,
you might have to have, like,
a handyman or a gas person.
And gas people don't like to fuck with these.
They want you to just, like,
not use them and put them in the trash pile and buy a brand new one.
So this is definitely an older model.
I can see the, uh.
The dials were a different colour.
That means They're like late 40s,
early 50s. And this is an older one, 1946.
I don't like this model. This one had the, uh,
mother in law cover, they call it.
So like when your mother in law came over,
you could just like slap the cover down and cover up your messes.
This one has it too. This one's $200.
It's not bad. Oh, no, sorry.
Just kidding. That's not a chambers.
Oh, this one's beautiful.
I love the colour. So they have some beautiful green ones and a blue,
a pink, a yellow.
I think the yellow is my favourite.
They're all like these candy pastel colours.
I think this is the one that Rachel Ray had in her kitchen too.
Again, this is the low back one,
so it's older than mine.
I've not ever seen one that has the same rings as me at mine.
Even like the same time period.
I'm trying to find a replacement ring because when I picked mine up,
I dropped it and cracked it.
So I really need to find one,
but I haven't seen one. This one says,
uh, very rare.
They have this. Overpriced.
Like just because it's the colour.
Yes,
it's still overpriced. It doesn't,
it doesn't. It's not being refurbished.
But here again is a mint green one again.
Oh, I didn't click on that one.
That one's 400 dollar. That one's old.
I probably wouldn't get that one.
That was pretty old.
That's like one Of their first models that look like that.
Personally,
unless you're gonna get that one fully refurbished professionally,
I wouldn't get that one. Here's another mint green one.
15. I don't know why they had it for 4,000, but
I don't know if that's dirty or they're not.
So if they now were chipped off there,
I think that's just dirt. You can see that door handle.
The door, the storage door,
pantry door there has been held up by string,
so that means the spring needs replacing.
There um,
doesn't look that bad honestly.
Just the price. 15.
It looks real rough and dirty,
but could be a good one. But 15?
That's kinda high. I probably wouldn't pay that.
If it was white, it wouldn't be worth anywhere near that much.
But it's green,
so maybe if you really wanted green one you'd pay that much.
See, this one's 2:25,
I think. No,
I haven't seen this one before.
This one's old. This one's older.
I I I like to try to stay between the the late 1950s
because that was like
the last time they made them in that style that I like.
Yep. There's another older ones.
400 if you like this style.
As the first one I ever saw was an older one,
so I fell in love with it when it was like a
an early 50s model and I liked it.
I just went out to see this fridge there.
Can't even say It. These stoves are so cool.
I wouldn't want one of my own house,
but they're so cool. So there's definitely options out there.
Keep looking. On marketplace,
I grab mine for $200, and I fix it up, and it's great.